[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
a parade
[Music]
at a
parade so no longer
are we safe at grocery stores no longer
are you safe at schools churches
but now
where we're supposed to
show our patriotism
for our country
of which
we have more slaughter
more slaughter
because a handful of people in this
country who own the gun manufacturers
need money they need [ __ ] money
profits
some [ __ ] ultra maga shooter
climbs a ladder
of a business
and rips apart people who are trying to
watch a parade
with an ak-47 or an ar-15 it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it doesn't [ __ ] matter
he bought it legally
and when they arrested him
they were really polite to him i mean
really polite
so it's nice that they were polite to
him really it's a good thing
they didn't put 60 bullets in him
i mean
if this [ __ ] idiot would have been
black they definitely would have put 60
bullets in him
we see that in ohio
it's up to you really to change this
everyone wants to talk about democrats
donations and the democrats this the
republicans that
it's your choice
you
decide
whether we keep doing this [ __ ] or not
and you say oh well i vote i go vote i
do this and i do that
i'm not talking about just your vote
we gotta come to our [ __ ] senses here
you got you gotta start you gotta start
using what you can to engage
in the civil discourse
i'm sure i'm sure there's all kinds
of second amendment bros that were at
the parade and as soon as they realized
there was gunfire those [ __ ]
fled
their instinct wasn't oh i should go
towards the gunfire and help out i'm a
good guy with a gun
nope
they ran away
because they were
being murdered
and then there's the debate rather this
[ __ ] idiot
is manga or he's not maga get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
we all know what the psychosis of this
son of a [ __ ] is
someone who randomly takes up on top of
a rooftop and starts murdering people
with a gun for fun
you think that has any any kind of
inclination of equality and equity
a pro-democracy
of having compassion sympathy or empathy
for other human [ __ ] beings [ __ ] no
it doesn't it's manga it's trumpism
through and through
from start to finish
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we know who they are we know how they
think
it's not complicated
trying to [ __ ] debate these idiots
because he dyed his hair once you dumb
[ __ ]
you are a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
if you think because he dyed his hair
once makes him a soy boy you are some
stupid [ __ ]
oh he looks weird with weird clothes
have you ever seen the buffalo q anon
shaman
the guy who stormed the [ __ ] capital
who's sitting in federal prison right
now because that dumb [ __ ] went
to a stupid costume shop and put on a
[ __ ] q and on costume you stupid
bastards
you are some dumb [ __ ] if you
think you're gonna convince us that
trump supporters don't dress up in
[ __ ] weird-ass costumes
and look like a bunch and act like a
bunch of [ __ ] queuing on weirdos
you are some dumb [ __ ]
you are you are yapping and talking to
the wrong [ __ ] people
we've watched you for [ __ ] six years
be [ __ ]
be weirdos do some weird wear some weird
[ __ ] wear [ __ ] trump flags like their
capes
wear [ __ ] buffalo horns and all kinds
of weird ass [ __ ] making [ __ ] trump
look like rambo putting flags all over
your [ __ ] trucks looking like a bunch
of goddamn cult members and you think
this weirdo somehow doesn't fit in with
you dumb sons of [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
of course he's a trump supporter
and the only reason why he's a trump
supporter is is because he's a piece of
[ __ ] garbage
got it
he's a piece of [ __ ] garbage
and he has no no [ __ ] sympathy or
empathy for human life
women children men innocent people
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's a trumper
i don't need to see pictures of him at a
[ __ ] rally either in a where's waldo
costume
it's [ __ ] sick we got a [ __ ]
sickness in this country
a sickness in this country
and they're using guns against us
ted cruz gives his thoughts and prayers
him and heidi oh they're thought they're
thinking and they're praying oh what
[ __ ] they've been thinking and praying
since [ __ ] buffalo they've been since
that manga king shooter went into the
[ __ ] grocery store and murdered black
people oh they've been thinking and
praying since you've already when 19
children got slaughtered thank god thank
god heidi and ted cruz are thinking and
[ __ ] praying thank [ __ ] god what
would we do without you ted get on a
[ __ ] plane and go to cancun and
[ __ ] stay there you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
people are pissed off
they're [ __ ] pissed off
they're [ __ ] pissed
and they're not pissed for the reason
that you [ __ ] trumpers think they're
pissed you stupid [ __ ]
they're not mad they're not mad because
of pronouns
they're not mad because people say gay
they're not mad they're not mad about
that they don't give two [ __ ] about
someone else's pronouns
or if someone's saying gay or not
are learning [ __ ] actual history
they're not pissed off about that
they're pissed off that they can't take
their [ __ ] family to a goddamn fourth
of july celebration and philadelphia
last night during the [ __ ] fireworks
people had to run and scurry because
there were [ __ ] people throwing
bullets
and you wonder why people are pissed off
you think you think you're standing
around wondering why people are [ __ ]
pissed
you people are taking away their [ __ ]
rights
you're trying to [ __ ] you're trying
to figure out who is in your ideology
and how you can kill the people who
aren't and get rid of the people who
aren't
and you're [ __ ] encouraging
encouraging your supporters to go out
and murder people with guns oh it's
backdoors today it'll be the [ __ ]
ladder on the back of the business
well god damn we need some ladder reform
you stupid [ __ ] you're encouraging
these people to do this
that's what you're doing
oh tony that's extreme no it [ __ ]
isn't
no it [ __ ] isn't
well it's democrats fault because they
won't do this or they won't do that shut
the [ __ ] up we're not gonna donate shut
the [ __ ] up that is not what is
happening you dumb [ __ ] out
there both sizing this [ __ ] both sizing
this [ __ ]
you're gonna lose your democracy and
you're gonna turn around and go why do
we lose our democracy because you're
both sizing everything
there is no two sides to this
majority of americans didn't want that
[ __ ] to have a gun
they didn't want that [ __ ] to
have a gun
most of americans
not not didn't want him to climb a
ladder on be on top of the roof
not they didn't want him to
dress up in weird [ __ ] clothes and go
to a [ __ ] cult meeting
not wanting him to [ __ ]
rap which i don't know what kind of
[ __ ] music you call that but jesus
christ
they didn't want him to have a [ __ ]
weapon of war
that's what most americans don't want
because it's the [ __ ] gun you dummies
it's the [ __ ] gun
and you're encouraging it you're and now
encouraging these shootings when you're
saying oh well back doors and we're
gonna send our thoughts and our prayers
jesus christ to handpick [ __ ]
governor
candidate for trump the trump hand-pick
candidate for republican governor in
illinois is like ah we need not 20
minutes after 20 minutes after people
were [ __ ]
broken apart by this motherfucker's gun
he's like ah we need to move on don't
talk about this
god if we talk about this i i might have
to answer questions about guns
that'll sound really [ __ ] stupid that
most people don't agree with
of course he will because he's a dumb
[ __ ]
trump endorsed him garen [ __ ] diet
and on and on it goes on and on it goes
and everyone's standing around trying to
point fingers whose fault it is well
point the finger back at yourself folks
that's right it's up to you it's you
you are the people you are the [ __ ]
government you are the democracy
you
you
i'm encouraged
watching the march
of people protesting
the overturning of roe
in particular women in this country not
taking this [ __ ] [ __ ] lying down [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
pissed
they're pissed about [ __ ] people
being murdered at a parade they're
pissed about
a young man being shot 60 [ __ ] times
60 [ __ ] wounds 60 [ __ ] bullets
they're pissed about some citizens being
second-class citizens in some [ __ ]
states and not they're pissed that these
[ __ ] fascists
don't
don't want to stay out of your goddamn
sex life and out of your [ __ ] love
life
they're starting to wake up to figure
out oh oh they are going to ban
contraception well son of a [ __ ] well
son of a [ __ ] roe v wade this wasn't
such a great thing after all to overturn
this thing
oh my god i thought they were just going
to celebrate that they overturned roe v
wade and stop no they're not going to
stop
they're not going to stop jesus christ
ron desantis signed a bill this morning
i guess
wanting to question
students ideology at universities
this did
listen everything they accuse
the left of doing is what they want to
do
that's what they want to do
listen to me when i tell you this and it
it sounds crazy i know i know it sounds
crazy
but doubt
me
if they get what they want and ban
abortion in all states
all states
everywhere ban abortion you will watch
these these anti-abortion pro-life
[ __ ]
fascists who who hate [ __ ] women
who hate [ __ ] liberals
they're gonna start they're gonna start
advocating for
forced abortion
that's what they'll start doing
the people who who are now are there
family against it and you're killing
babies it's to save the children
you give them the ability to ban
abortion outright all across the country
everywhere doctors women will be
prosecuted and made into felons
if they even there's a s [ __ ] whiff
that they would like to have a medical
procedure that is considered an abortion
those same [ __ ] those fascists
will start to dictate who and who cannot
get pregnant
they will talk about sterilization
they will talk about a better society
doubt me
doubt me it's coming it's coming they're
encouraging they're encouraging [ __ ]
weirdos to get [ __ ] weapons and use
them at [ __ ] fourth of july parades
oh tony no they are not got bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] they aren't
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] you have politicians
[ __ ]
posing with with weapons of war
as if they're awards
you have them going from saying all it's
for hunting it's for hunting oh it's for
tyranny is to take out tyrannical
politicians you have them saying that
you have eric greitens here in missouri
kicking in a door saying he'll kill
dissidents
they're encouraging it folks
they're encouraging it
and it's up to you it's up to you
it really is up to you
and i'm not just talking about your one
[ __ ] ballot
that you can mark
for who you want that's not what i'm
saying
i mean yes that that that that is a a
very very very
important right that you have to
exercise
is to actually mark the ballot
that's a very important right but you
have to get engaged
you have to do the whole democracy thing
you can't expect to just show up
on the day that you mark the ballot and
this come out the way that you want it
it's time for us pro-democracy people to
start taking some [ __ ] responsibility
and getting out there and doing what we
can do whatever your talent is
i'm not saying don't do anything you're
not good at do the things you are good
at that's what i'm saying
i'm good at being really [ __ ] pissed
and yelling and screaming for two hours
every goddamn day so i'm gonna keep
doing it
you might be good at texting you might
be good at writing letters
hell you might be good at knocking on
doors and talking to folks
because you're a likable
hell you might have some spare money in
your pocket so yes give to the [ __ ]
campaigns that are gonna make a
difference to get rid of these fascists
oh don't give to democrats that's the
dumbest that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing
i've ever heard of in my life and do you
know do you know on the dark web you
people out there who are saying don't
give the democrats on the dark web you
know what these [ __ ] mogalodites
these fascists are saying about you
these andy know these patriot front
types these nazis they're saying oh my
god look at them look at them they're
gonna they're gonna make themselves lose
they're excited about you telling
everyone to not give to democrats
because they know what that means
they're excited
so if you're saying it and you're
retweeting it and you're making videos
you're helping them
so use your talent for democracy not for
those [ __ ]
as much as you may be pissed off at
someone
direct your [ __ ] strategic outrage
where it needs to be directed
to [ __ ] like ron desantis greg
abbott
this dumb [ __ ] governor in ohio
who is forcing a [ __ ] ten-year-old to
drive across the state line because her
father raped her
get some [ __ ] strategic outrage and
point that son of a [ __ ] and use
democracy to crush these fascists don't
be talking about [ __ ] not donating to
the [ __ ] pro-democracy campaigns what
are you [ __ ] stupid
yes i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] point my
finger at you you goddamn right
this is why they always win and we
[ __ ] lose because they're always on
the same team no matter what
no matter [ __ ] what
they understand that it takes everyone
all the fascists every last one of them
to win the fascist fight and make this a
fascist state they understand that they
[ __ ] hate each other
you think they like each other they
[ __ ] hate each other
we have to be pro-democracy
not just yesterday not just today but
tomorrow next week next month and
continue and continue and continue
yeah we're gonna disagree and we ain't
gonna agree on [ __ ] that's all right it
doesn't [ __ ] matter we don't have to
agree on anything
and yeah you want to blame this person
or that person or this person on your
side fine whatever do it in private
you're making them excited you're
getting them all [ __ ] excited
so excited that they're they're going on
rooftops and murdering people
you think this guy did it out of some
kind of [ __ ] this guy this guy this
[ __ ]
is a trumped up white dude
and he's
and he's been he's been cultified
he's been cultified
so do your duty it's up to you it's up
to you it really is up to you
rather this [ __ ] continues or we put a
stop to this [ __ ]
oh but i'm i'm just one person yeah
exactly you're one person the next
person's one person you're one person
81 million people voted against fascism
folks 81 million [ __ ] because i
don't believe for a second i don't
believe for a second that 81 million
people voted because they were excited
about joe biden [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't convince me of it
but 81 million people knew the stakes so
there's at least
at least 81 million of us
and that was before before january 6
before i i don't know he [ __ ] tried
to take over and kill our government
with a coup
i was before all that
there's 81 million of us at least
and yeah i know the democracy is it's
it's [ __ ] difficult and right now
it's difficult because the way they
gerrymander the way they [ __ ] us with
the courts the way they're trying to
[ __ ] change laws
and i understand the supreme court is
trying to take away your rights but
while you still have them you better
[ __ ] use them
you better use them while you still got
them otherwise they'll just disappear
just just like they made all the excuses
in the world
to disappear roe v wade because that was
a decision that was bought and paid for
but go ahead go ahead and stand back
and watch the democrats lose and then
you can go see
because the reason why we're a fascist
state is because you lost because i
didn't donate to you and i didn't work
hard for democracy and i didn't vote
because i don't like you nah nah boo boo
stick your head and doo-doo
yeah okay that'll work yep because you
know what
you know this decisions that we have in
the supreme court that's the reason why
we have those decisions
because people don't engage in democracy
you have to engage
you have to engage
you can't just expect to vote or not
vote or wait for the perfect candidate
or wait for the perfect person
shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up get off your ass and go
do democracy
that's what we have to do here
and and it's working
trust me they're scared they see all
these women marching at these at these
road protests
these reproductive rights protests
and they're rethinking they're like oh
man maybe this [ __ ] whole row thing
overturning it this year wasn't a good
idea
they understand the stakes here if they
take the senate in the house they pretty
much guarantee themselves
a win in 2024 which basically makes us a
fascist state
sometime in
2025-2026
you realize that right
you know that's their plan
their plan is to take the senate and the
house
and do whatever they can to bang up
democracy to make sure in 2024 they
cheat and they win and they get the
house the senate and the presidency and
then sometime in 2025 2026 they will
come they will come down and the golden
escalator and say
i see we made this into a fascist state
and it doesn't matter which one of them
is going to [ __ ] run it folks
it doesn't matter if it's trump or
desantis or greg abbott or ted cruz it
doesn't [ __ ] matter they don't care
if you think they stay if they care at
this point
you have not been paying attention
they don't give a [ __ ] who the leader is
that's why the [ __ ] the trump
candidate for governor in illinois was
like oh move on from the shooting just
ignore that shooting
because uh it appears that he's a trump
supporter because uh he was murdering
people from a rooftop
with with a [ __ ] weapon of war
that's that's probably why he's a
trumper
everyone wants to blame it on mental
illness
yeah it is a [ __ ] mental illness this
cultism [ __ ] this trumpism [ __ ]
disguise this fascism disguises
patriotism
yeah it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
mental illness it is
you're [ __ ] out of your mind
you're out of your goddamn mind
so it's time for us us we we the people
we the people
to do democracy
you can do it i i'm telling you you can
do it
it's difficult but it's worth it it's
worth every single every single [ __ ]
inch every single millimeter
your freedom your rights and the rights
of others
the equality and the equity that we
could achieve
if we all and i mean all of the
pro-democracy people just just decide
that we're all on the same team here
we just got to work out the you know the
extra rules the details once we get in
charge
this all or nothing [ __ ] that's all or
nothing [ __ ] is gonna create a fascist
state folks it's going to
whether you like it or not whether you
want to [ __ ] believe me or you think
i'm some kind of [ __ ] bonehead
whatever
just doubt me
doubt me that if you don't if you don't
hold to the one principle of democracy
freedom liberty
if you don't hold
for equity equality and liberty for all
to that principle
and know
that yes even though they're
bastardizing the [ __ ] document
that we are using as the foundation of
our liberty and our freedom and our
equality and our equity in this country
for all people
all of them i don't care who you are
citizen non-citizen black white female
male trans
lesbian gay i don't give a [ __ ]
that document is the foundation
the absolute foundation
the thing that gives you your power
which is your liberty that is your power
and if you trade it away because you're
mad
because your side didn't do enough ten
years ago
when roe v wade wasn't gonna be
overturned
when this wasn't gonna be done when that
wasn't gonna be done
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] quit
crying
quit crying wipe those [ __ ] tears
away and let's punch back
i hear that all the time democrats
should punch back
well let's do that let's do that
the pro-democracy part of this country
should punch back yeah fine
we don't have to rely on the politicians
to do it for us
we can protest we can vote we can engage
it's our ballot it's our right
it's our liberty and we are the people
we are the government
it is us not them
not them
so let's all get on the same pro
democracy team here
and let's get rid of this [ __ ]
trumpism so we don't have more ultra
mega shooters
because that's what it is
that's what he was
was a trump supporter
he was a cultist he was an ultra maga
shooter
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots
what would you do if there was a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
[Music]
the sweetie sweets in the trendy trend
boy do we have a lot of stuff to get to
in the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends today holy [ __ ]
there's a lot of stuff going on i'm sure
there's stuff that's even breaking as
i'm as i'm speaking are yelling into the
microphone whichever
you would like to refer to
i see a lot of people said they needed
uh some of that energy today well you
can have it every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel for me
hit that subscribe button don't miss an
episode
here on the tony michael's podcast
that front rant boy
they they never disappoint me in giving
me something to yell and scream about
huh
whoosh
well we got a lot of stuff to cover
today um apparently uh there's a lot of
transphobia going around of course there
is
uh the the mogalodites are on the loose
uh there's news uh brittany griner
writing a letter to uh president joe
biden
there's the also
not just not just the shooting in
highland park uh fourth of july festival
but also philadelphia there's that with
mayor kennedy saying that he doesn't
want to be the [ __ ] mayor anymore
which you know
we'll evaluate that
um ak-47 and ar-15 of course is trending
because this [ __ ] ultra maga shooter
this ultra mega rooftop shooter
murdered women and innocent women and
children who were trying to watch a
parade
was
was able to buy a weapon of war
no [ __ ]
it's it's the gun dumb [ __ ] it's
the gun
now you got a lot of people claiming
that this [ __ ] bonehead is antifa or
some [ __ ]
somehow he's a liberal i don't know he's
[ __ ] rapping about ben shapiro and
all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] this guy's a
cultist
oh well he he looks weird really he
looks weird he doesn't look weird
[ __ ] in a crowd of you people
you ever seen [ __ ] video of a trump
rally holy [ __ ]
did you watch video of january 6
jesus christ there's a guy in [ __ ]
prison who went to a half-assed costume
shop and dressed up as a buffalo shaman
a q an honor
have you seen some of the outfits these
queuing honors wear
the [ __ ] out of here he looks weird
i mean
in comparison to what
not you people [ __ ]
he looks like a cultist to me
he's got all kinds of uh what looks like
donald trump insignia on his face he
tattooed his face
he's got 45 underneath his eye he's got
47.
on the side of his face he went to watch
trump's motorcade
at some point in 2020
the guys attended several trump rallies
the [ __ ] out of here and marjorie taylor
green says something about ssris
now i had no idea what ssris are i
didn't i did i have no idea i did not
know this
this morning i didn't know that that's
the the acronym right
for some
some medication for antidepressants i
didn't know that let's ask gabe let's
see if gabe knows what ssris were before
this morning gabe did you have any idea
what ssris i i did not know until i had
to go into the thread to find out i
actually had to google it because i i
mean i know what anti-depressants are
yeah yeah well that that's the acronym
for a specific type of one right yeah i
only know i only know them because um
i've got a few close friends who are on
right right um
and i only know specifically because
they were like oh i can't
they're like oh i don't like to mix
alcohol or this or that because it has
certain side effects so like i know
certain people that
are i have friends that take those
and
yeah yeah i know about it because i i've
known people that take i know people
that take you know antidepressants and
that sort of stuff too but i didn't know
at the designation but but it's
significant because
marjorie taylor greene tweets it as if
somehow
that's the reason why this guy did this
what the [ __ ] yeah i mean well that's i
mean like they're what they're gonna try
and do here is they're going to try like
they've already tried the mental health
right they've already gone for that
before and they said we've got a mental
health problem in this country and yet
we're not going to do anything about it
in terms of making health care more
affordable or making sure that you have
the proper resources
or
uh uh or funding or organizations
whatever to actually give you the need
that or the help that you need well [ __ ]
we had a back door problem game after
you rolled it i haven't seen any back
door legislation all right no i haven't
backdoor our backdoor funding oh i mean
not at all not at all yeah they
indicated that that was the problem
single entry in into a building was the
one thing we needed but they're like
that's what we need exactly i mean like
you look at the parade it you know
right why get over here
right wide open back doors at the parade
but on the ssri uh
the topic that you brought up they're
going to now i haven't read i i've been
doing other stuff this morning but i'm
going to guarantee or just assume that
what she's talking about is saying that
these
uh
this medication or these types of
medications are causing side effects for
those who take them so that then they
will now act out in a uh
malicious negative violent manner right
they're going to blame video games
they're going to blame
uh you know
pot psychosis aka reefer madness they're
going to blame antidepressants they're
going to blame any sort of medication
that somebody could take right but if
you look at this there's a screenshot
yeah
tweet like the the the fact that marjory
taylor green is now going to scapegoat
medication that is used for people to
help
is is insane right
it's backwards of what they're saying
right like the ssri
again i i i don't know the acronym i had
to look it up this morning but they're
antidepressants right that they're used
to help someone who actually has a
problem with depression which again
shouldn't be stigmatized that someone
with depression is violent or murderous
like that's not even that's so far from
the [ __ ] truth it's not even funny i
mean someone psychosis like a trump
supporter who is stoked up into these
ideas this q anon stuff this [ __ ]
trump loss and you have to be violent to
take back your government take back your
patriotism and [ __ ] like that now that
that
may be you know something to look at
right as far as mental illness and that
sort of thing but here she says marjorie
taylor green tweets when are we going to
have an honest conversation about drug
abuse mental illness and ssris we've
been having this conversation for like
30 [ __ ] years in this year
but also this is the same type of
approach that someone says just asking
an honest question you know right okay
right they already come in you see it on
tick tock you see it on uh twitter you
see on instagram someone who comes in
you say hey this is my standpoint uh we
should not have uh readily available
assault rifles so that anyone who turns
18 should have them we should not have
this available or whatever or whatever
whatever the take you want to have on
whatever the topic is
someone is going to come forward in one
of these comment sections it goes hey
look i'm an independent thinker i'm
neither left nor right
can you explain to me why this is this
way
but each time that somebody comes
forward and asks that question it's done
in a distant disgenuous way it's not
done with like good intent or or
sincerity or like hey i'm actually not
well informed on this i actually want to
learn something more about it but the
problem is that the people like margaret
taylor green is what are we gonna have
an honest conversation about this
one you don't know at all what you're
[ __ ] talking about like i personally
have experience with depression
especially in my family i know the the
toll that it can take on every family
member that is in the family and it's
not intentional right these are people
who
it's it's something that you don't want
to stigmatize and especially you don't
want to say that oh look if you have
depression and you take antidepressant
meds you are now going to grab a gun and
go shoot it's really stupid stuff it's
really stupid [ __ ] like why would you
why would you
uh in a group of of people who are
already vulnerable who already feel a
stigmatized kind of attack toward them
in society like oh something's wrong
with you you're not happy you're not
normal whatever it is
to take that group who already again
may or may not feel comfortable taking
this drug because again society has said
these people are deemed not normal
to then take it further and say oh hey
if you take the drugs to make you normal
because we said you weren't normal and
you needed to do something to be normal
those drugs will now make sure that you
act out in a violent manner
it is disgusting it is vile
it is
it is exactly what the republican party
will do
10 times out of ten
whenever there's a problem they'll find
a scapegoat and they'll point in the
opposite direction of what the real
problem is well well it's it's it's
obvious because they're losing their
minds over uh the ar-15 ak-47 this
morning on twitter the same way second
amendment and they keep they keep going
back to this guy was somehow uh antifa
because antiva's [ __ ] trending
because he colored his he dyed his hair
any any more funny outfits now now look
i understand i understand that he may he
may not have the exact wardrobe that
some people may like i i probably
wouldn't dress the way that he was
dressing and but here's the thing is
that that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're a [ __ ] mass shooter but it
definitely means that you might you
might be part of a group of people
to say that this guy because he dresses
weird
isn't part is cannot be part of magga
look look at this
i mean are you [ __ ] kidding me are
you kidding me that someone look at the
sunglasses they were like oh he's got
some kind of sunglasses on and he he
dyes his hair and he wears weird clothes
now someone uh mystery sullivan actually
said this is one of the funniest things
i've seen over the weekend
uh ask people to caption this picture
and i want to give people a laugh here
and someone's uh and i'll go ahead and
give him credit here on the show
someone's someone's response the best
caption i've seen was suck and blow
[Music]
[Laughter]
suck and blow is the uh caption for this
picture but to actually say that there's
no trump supporters out there that
that dress weird and have have weird
personalities and dye their hair there's
no way that this person is a true you
people are [ __ ] you're not fooling
anybody like we've watched you
for for six years be [ __ ] weird about
how you dress and how you
[ __ ] love donald trump and [ __ ] like
come on
give me a break
yeah these the people who are like oh
we're not in a cult you know we're not
weird and whatever it's like dude you
all wear the same [ __ ] [ __ ] you
bought the same stuff you already have
two mortgages on your house because you
you you know you started defaulting
payments because you had recurring
donations in the trump election defense
fund which was fake and you got [ __ ]
played
but these people that will continue
they'll name their children every single
trump child's name
you know i've made fun of it before for
trump derangement syndrome but it really
is a thing like these people are in a
cult and then they look at other people
like why are you so weird huh why are
you in a cult huh and it's like we don't
drive around like [ __ ] al-qaeda or
al-qaeda with uh
with flags and [ __ ]
guns strapped around our waist and
bazookas over our shoulders trying to
get a [ __ ] foot long subway sandwich
right we're not the weirdos in society
doing this
but these people these trumpers look at
us and they're like
you guys are
able to do whatever you want and like be
creative and like uh
i don't know not have to feel like
you're in the herd of the sheep here
and they look at us and like oh you guys
are so weird you guys are so weird
like the constitution literally says
that we should not be doing stuff like
this
but yet we printed on plates and forks
and hats and underwear and whatever else
you want
but they don't have a problem with that
part of the constitution that literally
says like don't desecrate the flag
in any sort of commercial product way
well the people that love the
constitution [ __ ] that
we're the weirdos we are the people that
are [ __ ] weird we're the people that
put trump's face on sylvester stallone's
body [ __ ] rocky and rambo it's really
weird does that
weirdos do people with some sort of
break
i mean again it just it it doesn't it
doesn't compute that just because this
guy dyes his hair
and wears
and wears weird clothing
makes him
not
not maga i mean of course he's manga now
now a lot of people are referring to the
um
the picture of him
showing up at a trump rally and what
appears to be now i mean i i i can't um
you know confirm that this guy was
trying to do this
but he looks like he was uh where's
waldo
well not only that but he's trying to be
captain magga over here where he's got
the flag around his right right yeah
that's that's the other picture that's
going around where he's got the flag and
he he's also uh put out rap music
talking about ben shapiro um he's he
also showed up to a trump motorcade at
one point cheering on trump i mean uh
obviously this guy has trump derangement
syndrome i mean there's no doubt that
that's what it is um you gave me a tweet
here another tweet of marjorie taylor
greens is that right yeah what's this
here
this one
okay well we'll read the first part of
it okay read the first part and then
we'll go to what her quote tweet of her
own tweet is okay so so um
this was four hours ago she tweeted this
uh-huh
oh jesus christ
okay four hours ago marjory taylor green
tweets and and i don't want to show many
pictures of this guy today yeah yeah but
i am gonna show this one uh in reference
to what she's talking about here because
this is really [ __ ] boneheaded
she she writes the public should not
allow this to continue people are not
stupid and she asked a question here she
says is he in jail or rehab or psychiat
psychiatric center in this photo now i'm
going to show you this photo here okay
remember what she's saying about this
photo this is not his bedroom okay she
is sure that this is some kind of jail
rehab or some kind of psych facility
22 years old 5 11 and 120 pounds is not
normal or healthy
i i'm not sure i guess i guess she's
saying he's not as muscular as she is so
oh yeah she's like look he's not in the
crossfit gym with me this is a normal
weight he's not power cleaning his own
weight um what drugs or psychiatric
drugs or both does he use
so in other words they're like this is
all mental health it's not the gun but
don't give people mental health care
they're advocating two different things
here like you were saying earlier but
here's the picture i want to show you
this picture
this is the picture she's referring to
which is clearly i mean it doesn't take
a [ __ ] brainiac to realize
that this is not only a photoshop it is
a horrible photoshop gabe even i even i
um as limited in my skills as i am which
you know i am yeah i could have made
this look i mean the thumbnail you made
last week was way
here's the other thing too is the last
line in this tweet before we read the
quote tweet she says what drugs or
psychiatric drugs or both does he use
now i find this funny and i don't know
if people have brought this up but i'm
gonna i'm gonna tweet this out in a
second is the fact that drug use
right treatment
is protected
under hipaa
wait wait wait wait wait wait you mean
this is his hipaa
you mean this this is his yeah yeah yeah
well well you mean she she's violating
his hipaa
like she you know and when someone asks
if she has a vaccine she's like oh
you're violating my hipaa exactly it's
the exact same thing to disclose if
somebody else were to disclose that they
would be revealing information that it's
between a patient and their provider
their doctor
and you as you know yourself as the
patient so whoever is doctor you can't
even get your own medical records
without giving yourself permission or
without giving your doctor permission to
give them to you and exactly but she it
goes even further than that because she
confuses hipaa when someone asks her in
public if she's got a vaccine she thinks
that breach which that's that's not that
doesn't break your hipaa you can either
say yes no or [ __ ] you or whatever no
comment um
whatever you want to say that's not
actually breaking your hip bringing your
hip is when the doctor actually gives
information that without your permission
yeah but or someone else like if someone
else like the only way that someone
would be able to give this information
would be to be if it was your doctor or
someone else just like got access to
these records which again against the
law right but here's the thing
is she thinks when someone asks about
your health condition or your treatment
of your health condition she thinks that
just asking is breaking your hipaa just
asking yes but
she's doing that right here in this
tweet she's like hey look i want you to
find out what medication this guy was on
where he was treated and what he was
treated for
i wonder what we should have a
discussion about that let's bring that
out
like you know if those are details that
are revealed
by the party fine obviously shit's gonna
come out it's illegal if it does but if
there were other people in the family
that revealed it again
well yeah but the only the only the only
entity other
than him or his guardian that can
actually release that information is the
court the court is the only one so i
mean like it was brought up on record to
say like this person was under these
drugs and under this influence assuming
that was some sort of argument that they
wanted to make to say this person was on
not under the right mind because they
were under a medication that caused them
to grab a gun and shoot people which
which i mean anti-depressants aren't
aren't
there there's no proof that they're a
violent drug
right there's no proof at all if that
was the case then the fda would say yo
okay we've been following these drugs
for years and we're finding that people
are grabbing guns and shooting people or
doing anything else that's violent but
again that's why ssris are are trending
this morning and i i never heard that
acronym before i've heard again of
antidepressants right but i never heard
it called that acronym before because i
don't i didn't know what it stood for
but
here she is these people who are saying
because you're going to blame it on
mental health
uh soon that's the you know that's the
cycle they'll blame it on mental health
it'll be he's mentally ill he's a wacko
that's kind of what she's doing here
but she's also doing the opposite of
saying we need more mental health right
just like we need more back door reform
i mean they're gonna get to the ladder
because there's the story that the um at
one of the press conferences the law
enforcement said something about an
unsecured ladder so i'm sure they're
going to want to have a ladder reform on
the back of businesses here soon
but marjorie gay they're green here this
dumb [ __ ]
she quotes she quote tweets her own
tweet
and i i believe it's probably because
people pointed out that she's a dumbass
yep
she says and i actually i actually uh um
and retweeted someone saying so
commenting on her commenting on this
but she said supposedly this is
photoshopped supposedly what do you mean
supposedly no it is it is it's not hard
to know like you just it's horribly
photoshopped it's not even a good
photoshop more reasons to release his
records so here she's violating his
hipaa what's wrong with him like what do
you mean what's wrong with it what what
in what world is it more
mentally unstable to have a really
horrible photoshop and you believed it
then right then this guy is but also
rooftops murdering people right but then
she takes this opportunity to be like oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna save my ass here a
little bit and i'm gonna say supposedly
this is f
no no not at all
it doesn't take [ __ ] csi forensics to
look at this enhance rotate enhance zoom
in and then say oh look at the hair and
there's white lighting behind but it's a
more of a yellow room tint going on but
he's blurry but the background's in
focus like it doesn't take a [ __ ]
genius to do this you're looking good
there you
go yeah
i think it was the good lighters that i
that i retweeted because they said this
is what they said someone dumb enough to
believe q anon would be fooled by an
obvious photoshop yep
yep
yep
it what a [ __ ] bonehead what a
[ __ ] bonehead uh there's gonna be a
lot of boneheads this week because
they're gonna be a lot of [ __ ] takes on
this oh oh yeah yeah i mean even
starting last night there were already
[ __ ] takes but yeah today it's like
let's go let's go blame the drugs okay
and it you know outside of the fact that
again
these people these republicans don't
want to do anything in terms of actually
treating mental health or are offering
the proper care and facilities and
resources and funding for this
they're also the people that are like oh
we hate big pharma you know oh but at
the same time we're gonna
let big pharma dictate the price right
because
we uh
we we are we are paid by the lobbyists
that tell us how we should vote on these
things but outside in the public we're
going to complain
and we're going to blame these things
and actually help a lot of people
right and you're going to try and blame
it and say that if you take this drug
you could be the next mac next mass
shooter like the idea
that you would try to put that already
in someone's brain that is dealing with
this that is that may not even know
what's going on right they might like i
don't know what's going on i you know
i'm i'm moody or i'm this or i i have
i'm kind of lethargic or i'm not feeling
this way like not know that they're
actually depressed get treated
because they're like oh [ __ ] i need to
find out what's going on told you like
hey
this is what seems to be the the the
issue at play and we're going to put you
on some medication oh no no i don't want
to do that because i don't want to be
the next mass shooter
like if that's the kind of narrative
they're going to go with they're again
they're hurting they don't care about
life they don't they're not pro-life
it it really is it well of course
they're not pro-life we've proven that
time and time again they've proven it to
us
um you know speaking of
uh
pro-life america on patriot day on on
the 4th of july yesterday at highland
park
um
was not the only shooting yesterday at a
fourth of july event this is a mayor ken
kenny
uh he's reacting to two officers being
shot
during the fireworks at philadelphia now
i'm not familiar with philadelphia but
apparently it was that it happened
inside of a park
that's close by where the fire you know
people gathered there so they could see
the fireworks
um
apparently shots rang out and the story
is that that i can tell the best that i
can tell is officers were telling people
to leave the area because of the gunfire
so of course people you know seeing the
news from earlier that day they [ __ ]
ran like their lives depended on it
because that would be a totally normal
response that somebody has right because
the other thing too is in that in the
videos from that parade in highland park
there's a there's a bit of a delay there
because people don't know what the
[ __ ] going on you've got lots of
sounds you know it's fourth of july in
the confusion
right right you've got people talking
you're hearing something in the distance
you go oh someone's lighting up
fireworks during the day which people do
you know despite the fact that like i
wouldn't really see it but
you see people and you hear people light
fireworks off they're making a lot of
noise and a lot of commotion and then
you hear like that
that that that that that you
you see the the the delay naturally
anyone would to be like wait what the
[ __ ] and then you see everyone running
and they're like wait what and then they
start running like it's a it's a domino
effect of people like progressing
through the parade as they respond to
hear something that they again
would not
expect to be at the 4th of july
independence
america's holiday
like
there's there's no way that republicans
talk can talk they can try but they
can't talk their way out of this
well i i mean i think you make a lot of
good points there about the sound and
and and you know not really computing
that what was happening at the event
that it was happening i mean you even
see this inside of um
some of these events where they've
captured
um footage of the shooter walking into a
school or something like that it's it's
almost like you know it's you know it
can happen in this country every day it
happens every day in places that you
wouldn't imagine but your brain still
doesn't really compute um for several
seconds that it is happening inside that
i mean it just it's it's craziness but
here is the gov excuse me the mayor of
philadelphia um not wanting to be the
mayor anymore
he says in this clip which you know i
mean this is the saddest part about this
all and i don't know if he's a good man
or a bad man i have no idea really
honestly um but
the the the exhaustion
of this of this
and that's their goal folks that's what
i was trying to tell you in the first 30
minutes this is their goal to exhaust
you to just give up on democracy to just
give the [ __ ] up not just lay down and
let them have what they want which is a
fascist state and it's not trust me it's
not gonna be worth it if you do that you
gotta fight with every [ __ ] inch of
your life
but listen to mayor kennedy here
describe the events that happened in
philadelphia not highland park we're not
talking about the shooting high in the
park we're talking about another
shooting in a fourth of july celebration
in philadelphia listen yeah here it was
a laid-back chill day
weather was beautiful
concert was beautiful
but we live in america and we have the
second amendment and we have the supreme
court united states telling everybody
they can carry a gun wherever they want
it's like dodge city i mean so like we
have to come to grips with what the
problem then
what he said there about dodge city is
um actually
if you go back and you look at dodge
sitting in the laws um at certain points
of time to dodge city kansas we're under
in the wild west because that's what
he's kind of referring to is the wild
west
actually when you came into town and
dodge city at certain points in their
history you actually had to check your
guns is what they would call it and
there were signs at when you came into
town so you have to check your guns
because they knew even then that it's
really dangerous to have a bunch of
people especially people who are all you
know
uh off off the trail and
and have access to you know booze and
drugs and sex and all this stuff and
they get into fights and they get
scurried and they have enemies and they
meet their enemies in town probably not
a good idea to interject guns into that
whole mix yeah it's almost like someone
who's emotional and maybe has to deal
with some issue you're like ah let's not
throw kerosene on the fire okay if you
want to fight
fight with your hands
don't call it the [ __ ] guns right
even dodge city back in the wild west
understood that so i just want to point
that reverence out that he's making in
dot city well listen to what the mayor
says here about his job it's uh it's
actually
oh it's kind of disheartening but listen
what this country is about right now
a lot of a lot of goofballs out there
with guns and they can get them anytime
they want so this is what we have to
live with people are asking
what's the mayor doing about this i have
the ability
to take care of guns i would
but the legislature won't let us the us
congress won't let us
um the governor does the best that he
can our attorney general does the best
he can but this is a gun country i'm
concerned every single day there's not
an event or a day where i don't lay on
my back and look at the ceiling and
wonder worry about stuff
i'll be happy when i'm not here when i'm
not mayor and i can enjoy some stuff
you're looking forward to not being
mayor yeah
whoo holy [ __ ] man i mean
and it's all because of the
he's saying he's saying it's it's the
gun it's the gun that's the gun it's got
his gun right it's the [ __ ] gun like
that's the majority of my problems is
the [ __ ] gun and if i could do
something about it i would but i can't
what am i gonna do
what am i gonna do be putting cuffs
because i'm
enacting walls that
i don't have the authority to enact it
it really is
and i and i know people want to blame it
on this or that right you know and he
tried to press the blame on that the
state legislator won't let him the the
congress won't let him
like the supreme court [ __ ] overturn
the 100-year law in new york in the
state of new york for carry and carrying
weapons
i mean it really is it really is
i mean i mean you know it's like can you
blame him though like he's be he's in
that moment he's like
i feel helpless right like i i live in
an area where i have to wake up every
day and wonder will there be a shooting
today right will it happen in my area
well will i be the person that has to
take up
and deal with this issue and
unfortunately
yesterday was that day but it does wear
you down where you're like [ __ ] man i
just wanted to make things better for
the people that live in my city or my
town
i don't have to deal with this other
[ __ ] because you guys have tied my
hands behind my back and said all of
these people can have guns and open
carry or we won't we won't prosecute
them the same way or whatever it might
be right like there are certain extra
protections given to obviously a white
person with a gun than someone who's of
color with a gun right
and he's just
being human in this moment where he's
like
i'm like i'm sick of it
he's like i just want it like i didn't
want to deal with this this definitely
wasn't like
like i knew this would could be a
possibility but i never thought like
yeah it's gonna [ __ ] happen in my
town my city right this is the guy who's
like yeah i just want to like yeah i do
expect i cannot wait for the day that my
term is over because then i won't have
to deal with all the pressures i could
just be a citizen
you know maybe have my own frustrations
with the government and the people that
rule the area but
it's like yeah what do you expect
not even police want to have to deal
with this [ __ ] you saw it in uvalde and
now you're seeing the people that are
actually in charge after a mass shooting
like [ __ ] man
fourth of july i was here we were having
a good time we were listening to music
we were with family with friends i was
having a beer like whatever it might be
and then you're like there was a
shooting you're like [ __ ] man
like i don't want to deal with that i
i'm telling you and and there's all
kinds of [ __ ] going around um it's a
lot of transphobia and a lot of phobia
for lgbtq members and nikki freed she's
running for
governor
uh in florida
as a democrat she posted this video i
want to show you this video
uh she said i'm posting this with her
mother's permission because uh i need
everyone to see what rhonda santa's
florida really looks like
and this is all part of this fear of
guns
this is all part of it this is all part
of the authoritarian plan the fascist
plan
and this girl that you're gonna see in
the video is 13 years old okay and nikki
freed points out 13 years old being
arrested for protesting for their own
freedom now again this is a video of a
13 year old girl uh nikki free posted
and she says she has the mother's
permission here at a protest
so this is at a protest
um where they're they're they're
protesting for people's rights not to be
taken away from them yeah
totally radical crazy well and watch
watch as they arrest her
um what kind of flag she's carrying what
kind of flag they they collect as
evidence here watch
lily just don't resist
really don't resist honey it's okay
it sounds like the mother's in the
background i'm not sure if that is the
mother or yeah someone some maybe parent
or someone that they're they obviously
know her because they know her name
they're telling her not to resist now if
you see the two the two fascists here
that are arresting uh i think i think
they yell their name was lily
um
if you see them here they've got one of
her flags here and it's it's a rainbow
flag yeah and then oh boy man i feel
super threatened by that right now right
i mean these guys definitely were they
were definitely threatened by this 13
year old girl not only having an lgbtq
rainbow flag but also it looks like it
appears to be
a flag that is in support of transgender
people uh on her back yeah right it's
like you know someone who wants equal
rights for everyone anyone right is like
nope can't do that we don't acknowledge
those people they're not real it's like
right now now now this is in florida
where they keep saying
that parents are
are
you know
deluding the kids or grooming the kids
or whatever and it's all about blah blah
blah but here they're arresting a child
they're arresting a child who had a who
had a rainbow flag right now watch watch
as they put her in because i think the
most significant part of the video
is that is at the end when the cops get
in the car because they don't like throw
the flags on the ground watch what
happens
your mom's right behind you yeah it is
her mom she's yelling that is her mind
my name's renu
what's their names oh they have to take
that all right hey guys breaking the law
hey you're okay mom's right here
so they put her in the back of the car
now watch him he rolls up her flag
and he collects it as evidence
he doesn't want anyone to have that plan
i mean god damn gabe can you imagine can
you imagine if someone on the street had
access to a rainbow flag how [ __ ]
dangerous that could be on the fourth of
july jesus christ gabe there are parades
on the fourth of july you can't let
people run around with [ __ ] rainbow
flags this is craziness what are we
doing in this country we must we must
ban rainbow flags at all of our
patriotic vents because it's dangerous
it's so dangerous that rainbow vlogs so
much so that they must confiscate it
they they're coming for your flags and
we're gonna come get your flags it
really is [ __ ] i mean it just i mean
i don't know i mean uh based on what
probably desantis and those cops believe
you could probably kill a lot of people
within minutes with those [ __ ]
rainbow flags probably more people than
an assault rifle right there it's
boneheaded type stuff it really is i
mean that they really are more afraid of
the rainbow flag than they are of an
ak-47 or an ar-15
they're they're uh terrified terrified
terrified that gay people may have
rights
the only difference
is they're willing to then go
and fight or go and arrest or take that
person into custody right they're afraid
of the flag so we gotta act on it now
we're afraid of the guns we gotta we
gotta wait on this guys we gotta wait on
this also sir can you please get out of
the car i'm asking very nicely oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's let's go to the uh
because i don't want to say this guy's
name but we're going to go to the thread
here
and we're going to see some pictures of
him i really don't want to show pictures
of him but
we're going to see it because
frankly at one point in this in this um
in this
tragic story where this [ __ ] idiot uh
took a a weapon of war and went and
murdered people at a fourth of july
celebration at a thing like a [ __ ]
parade um
there's a point where they were looking
for him because they didn't apprehend
him right away right now it's very
unclear to me rather
um his dad owns the building that he was
on top of there's some reports saying
that he was or he wasn't
but i can't get a clear um sense through
the reports of what building he was
standing on yeah so sure i'm sure in the
next few ways
we will know that but so after so uh
when i text you so for context for
people like um highland park i don't
know if you already talked about this
but like no no i i haven't talked about
what island park is or where it is or
right
because you're you're from the chicago
area yeah you know the surrounding areas
pretty well so i i have a specific tie
to highland park actually at the moment
right now
um but highland park it you know i i
grew up in the suburbs and in chicago
and highland park is a very affluent
suburb right the the media there's some
really famous people who are yeah right
there or live there yeah like michael
jordan lived there uh i think isn't
charlie kirk from highland park isn't he
from no
he might be excellent i think charlie
kirk is from highland park um there's a
there's uh from what i understand over
the weekend when this happened there's a
there's a very
significant jewish population in in
highland park
um as well
no he's from charlie kirk is from
arlington heights arlington heights but
if i look up uh
nick fuentes because he's also from the
chicago area
is he from island park
nick fuentes is
from
he's uh it says chicago i don't know
yeah well
the other the other thing too oh western
springs looks like
the other the other thing too about um
island park
is
that because a lot of people like oh
look chicago and i'm like well no i mean
i mean i mean it is chicago suburb right
like yeah it's part of greater chicago i
mean you describe it you're from there
tell us okay so
highland park has anyone seen well i
guess i'm sure someone has seen any of
the john hughes films you look at home
alone 16 candles breakfast club ferris
bueller's day off you've got risky
business these though you know some of
those things were filmed in la
those places that they're set the john
hughes universe and all those places are
set in the north shore area the north
shore for anyone who doesn't know is
like new in the new trier area winnetka
highland park
um evanston you know those are areas
which is like old money this is like
money money this is you know
established money through
generational wealth
the people that live there
are are white
they have money they come from a good
background they have a good education
you've got a few actors who have come
from that area you have michael jordan
who once lived there
um this is an area that is not
uh
accustomed to this type of violence this
type of of kind of um
activity
the other thing that my tie comes to
personally is my my dad owns a
restaurant that is no
no further than 400 500 feet away from
where the shooting happened
now luckily the restaurant was closed
yesterday and he was out of the country
because i
in a in a in a moment of panic
i texted my dad to be like i just saw
there was a shooting at the at the
corner of second and central are you
okay are you at work right now
and then i was like oh [ __ ] i'm not
hearing a response and then i called my
dad and then it wasn't going through
and i was like oh [ __ ]
and then i realized that uh when i
called again it was going through
international so he was out of the
country visiting family in mexico
so luckily the restaurant was closed he
was out of the country he's actually
coming back
but he was getting messages at that time
after it happened to be like hey sergio
this is what's going on this is what's
going on we've got these you know
there's a shooting that happened
uh it was in the neighborhood down the
street
and um
when i spoke to him
i one was very very relieved because he
wasn't there and i was very relieved
that no one was working there obviously
was not relieved that that happened in
the neighborhood
but that is how
like this could happen to anyone right
like if the circumstances were different
like my dad potentially could have been
a victim not saying he was but i'm
saying like
he's down the block right so i i've yet
to speak with him because he's kind of
you know dealing with traveling all the
like should we open the restaurant back
up or anything like that and so i'm
gonna i i mean to ask him to see like
for the for the uh for the the rumor
that's going around which is like
his dad owned a sandwich shop or a
restaurant yeah that's what they're
saying and i think he ran for mayor to
you as someone right right so when i get
a hold of my dad uh i do plan to ask him
about this now if there's more details i
want to know like
did you know this guy do you know who
they're talking about did you ever go
there kind of thing
um because i'm curious myself but i
personally have a first i've got a i've
got an account i've got someone who is
from that area that is there you know
every day so
right they're right there right there on
that corner right right there
there's there's some people saying that
um and it looks like there's a police
cameras justin has it posted here about
uh looks like there was an update about
30 minutes ago or so
um about the shooter now again yesterday
even yesterday after they caught him and
i'm going to show you a little bit of
that footage
because
it's it's very
it's very weird footage to see after uh
some ohio police officers
put 60 rounds into a blackmail
but and how they apprehended
and you know were very polite and wanted
him to be polite but justin has supposed
to hear this video um it is pulled from
fox news
the press conference here says law
enforcement announces that they believe
the shooter i'm not going to say his
name uh pre-playing this because here's
the thing
we don't need to say his name anymore
because we're not looking for him so and
just the way it is he's the ultra maga
shooter he's the ultra maga rooftop
shooter to me um but the ultra magaz
rooftop shooter quote pre-planned this
attack for several weeks so let's listen
to the uh
the press conference here it's a couple
minutes long let's listen to what they
had to say
thus
further the investigation and aid
investigators one point i just want to
clarify is robert cremo the third he's
21 he'll be 22 in september of this year
and he's a resident of highwood
so it sounds like they had that fact
wrong yesterday um that he was almost 22
he wasn't 22. actually i think that's
what they're trying to say there so
throughout the past 24 hours
investigators have spoken with numerous
witnesses
some of the survivors they've had the
opportunity to review numerous video
clips uh both from cell phone video
recordings and fixed cameras in the area
so that was one thing gabe that
yesterday that me and you were texting
back and forth because we were trying to
figure out a lot about this event right
as it was ongoing because i know you you
kind of had the uh the situation with
you know your dad being close by in that
proximity um on a regular basis for what
he does for work but and i know you you
were you know worried about it until you
found out that he was okay um but we
also were we i was confused because when
you went to twitter and it was you know
trending at the top yeah um twitter
actually had the trending topic
of highland park uh and the top results
uh
uh scrubbed there you couldn't find you
had to go to the latest tab
is what you had to do um to get any of
the results not the top tab or the
trending tab um but i believe it's
because of what this officer is saying
is because there was probably a lot of
cell phones right because it was a
parade there was probably a lot of
footage and i think probably law
enforcement didn't want some of the most
gruesome footage leaking its way
and twitter was kind of like well maybe
we should um make sure which i think is
actually wrong
because i think we should not look away
from this event i think we should watch
these videos of this parade and i think
you should actually think to yourself
this can happen if you go look at those
images it's not like some big city
highland park is not some big [ __ ]
city with skyscrapers and [ __ ] that's
not what this is
it it is it the the downtown area falls
feels like an american small town
anywhere right like that's why when you
brought up john hughes earlier that's
why john hughes would shoot a lot of
these movies there is because it was
quote unquote middle class america right
like that that's the reason why he shot
a lot of those movies in the 80s there
is because it would portray that was the
perfect picture of middle class america
right um
so i think that's why what he's saying
here is there's a lot of footage and i
think that's why they identified him
also if it is true that it was his
father's shop that's probably another
reason listen to what else the
officer has saved
and they've con conducted a number of
other follow-up investigations and based
on where we're at at this point in the
investigation and some of this is still
preliminary so is subject to change as
we keep moving forward but we do believe
cremo pre-planned this attack for
several weeks
which if you actually go um gabe
yesterday when we were trying to figure
out who this guy was i actually went to
his youtube channel now they took it
down soon after
they actually i i was trying to use our
download tool yeah let's write it down
and youtube was not allowing the videos
to be pulled like it wasn't it wasn't
allowing there's errors yeah yeah so
youtube was actively i mean very quickly
i mean you're talking
what was it probably a half an hour 45
minutes after the event that i was yeah
right
what other kind of download tool can i
use because i was trying to pull that
stuff so that we had it in case someone
would [ __ ]
you know try to say something that it's
not or try to change the video
yeah you you sent it to me uh and i was
i was away from the the house but you
sent it to me and i watched the videos
you know short clips but enough where
it's like
[Music]
seems like there was uh something
brewing here right right and that's and
most of his videos were
uh
more than two weeks old and i don't
think there was one of them on there
that wasn't um
younger i guess right
than maybe three or four months um he
had a one video on there that was kind
of like a music video it was really you
know most people would consider it a
little weird yeah
unless you're into that kind of music or
whatever because this music was a little
it won my taste in music but it is what
it is apparently he had a fan base but
he was talking about a lot of weird
stuff in his music which i don't think
that's what caused this everyone wants
to make it about the music and [ __ ] and
yeah maybe he was signaling and he was
definitely giving sending some signals
out there but i don't think the actual
type of music itself
or the genre music itself is what drove
this kid to do this yeah and i think i
think he was placing his ideas inside
that genre of music which seemed you
know kind of suspicious but he but the
youtube channel was taken down almost
immediately now i did grab i did grab a
video which we're gonna show people that
post on the internet otherwise um of the
uh where they're at the trump motorcade
i'm gonna play that video i want to at
least but let's listen to what the
police officer has to say
because he's saying here that he planned
it for weeks but i'm saying based on his
youtube channel
this guy may have been thinking about
this for many many months because a
couple of the videos actually to me it
shows that area where he was shooting
um it shows a video
of of that area that street now again
if if the significance is the shooting
or the significance is maybe he's there
a lot because his dad had a a business
there you know we're we're unsure about
that but let's listen to the rest of the
bears
he brought a high-powered rifle to this
parade and no [ __ ] he accessed the roof
of a business via a fire escape ladder
and began opening fire on the innocent
independence day celebration goers
the rifle was purchased in illinois and
the information we have thus far is that
it appears to have been purchased
legally oh
well that's kind of convenient isn't it
yeah that's kinda can mean oh my god
these criminals will get these guns no
matter what kind of laws you pass well
here's the thing in illinois and i don't
i don't know gabe do you know that gun
laws knowing oh it does not does not
have a relaxed gun monster yeah this kit
this kid to get a gun in illinois
he had to jump i mean it's legally
purchased right like it's one yeah and a
lot of people are going to say oh well
see there's all kinds of regulations and
he's still got it but yes that's what
we're trying to tell you yeah that's
what we're trying to say
is that even the regulations the most
strenuous
regulations in illinois are not enough
they're not enough for weapons of war
they're not enough you got you got to
make sure
that that a bonehead who wants to kill
people doesn't have this weapon as and
you're not going to prevent it yeah yeah
yeah people are still going you know
people are going to find it's i mean you
look at it and you're like oh
kind of relief he didn't get it
illegally and that's somebody was
selling it but then you're also like oh
[ __ ] man it's like you do have this
moment where yeah even the strictest
laws and people are always gonna use
chicago oh we've got strict gun laws in
chicago but all the violence it's like
dude this wasn't in the inner city
this wasn't in the inner city where they
keep making this claim right because i
know fox news is going to try to use
that [ __ ] oh yeah no 100 percent they
will say
words like black on black crime for
highland park yeah they're going to say
highland park uh they're going to say
something where you know even though
it's
not near the city like to get to
highland park from downtown or even the
[ __ ] south side of chicago where
somebody wants to argue it's inner city
problems
it's a drive it is age [ __ ] drive
it is not you know even from the area in
which they took him which was further
north from where the shooting happened
that's 20 minutes
that's like 20 minutes that's a 20
minute drive
then to get from highland park to
downtown depending on traffic
for another 45 minutes maybe an hour
depending on what time of day it is like
especially what what part of the city
you're trying to get into like it's not
it's not just like a
you know [ __ ]
uh just right across the street it's not
like down the block
it's a trek away again
this is an affluent neighborhood mostly
white people rich people
good education
who many people that have the you know
middle class
middle class white america is what it is
middle class white america and i gabe i
said it i don't know if i would even say
middle class white america is what this
neighborhood is like this is this is
money money this is like it is it is
upper class like middle class well yeah
but but we've been we've all been
brainwashing to think thinking that even
upper middle class isn't middle class
they're middle class
this idea this idea that somehow these
people in this area have the most amount
of money of anyone ever ever yeah come
on i i really believe that this is the
image of middle class america this is
what middle class wants to be and should
be they should be this level um
there's there's people telling you to
check your dm's game i did yeah yeah i
just saw it what was there is there a
link is there breaking news or something
no no no no
kailyn had sent me the sunday review
remember when they came out and they're
like authority said the gunman was able
to legally obtain the weapon you know
right and
that's the she sent me the the headline
or the
the print out of the sunday paper well
here's here is uh let's finish the rest
of this press conference because i want
to go to the video of his arrest and i
also want to go to some of the video of
the of the actual shooting itself so you
can hear the gunfire because we can't
look away from this by cremo
during the attack primo was dressed in
woman's clothing and investigators do
believe he did this to conceal his
facial tattoos and his identity and help
him during the escape with the other
people who were fleeing the chaos
during the attack we believe that cremo
fired more than 70 rounds from this
rifle into the crowd of innocent people
following the attack cremo exited the
roof he dropped his rifle and he blended
in with the crowd and he escaped uh he
walked to his mother's home who lived in
the area and he blended right in with
everybody else as they were running
around almost as he was
an innocent spectator as well
he borrowed his mother's vehicle
we issued an alert yesterday afternoon
chief jockman uh provided the vehicle
information and primo's information
we're very thankful that an alert member
of the community saw primo's vehicle
traveling southbound on route 41
an
dialed
north chicago police officer spotted the
vehicle waited for additional backup
units so it did work by by getting it
out there on the internet that this guy
was driving this car that was the only
thing i will say this like i don't like
to share the people's names or their
photos or whatever but at the time he
was right he was because of and
obviously because of i've got family and
friends in chicago this one kind of hit
close to home
uh
and that was the only time and as soon
as they caught him
right now i took away the the retweets
that i had just because
there was no need to share his face or
his name anymore in my book now if you
if you look down here um at the bottom
right of the of this screen here you'll
see the car and where they arrested him
at an intersection now they said uh 41 i
think it was highway 41. this is in lake
forest illinois so how far away because
you kind of know the area gabe how far
away is lake forest from highland park
it's like
17 minutes
20 minutes so he drove he was driving
away yeah he was driving north now the
question is like where was he driving to
was he trying to go north over the
border into wisconsin i don't know i
could only imagine that if you're
driving north away from a crime scene
it would seem like you're trying to get
into another area right right you would
try to go north
well
but really honestly um
it sounds like this guy playing this
attack right right he planned this
attack because he was he was dressed up
to to make sure to be part of the crowd
that he wasn't beyond identified because
he's very identifiable and what i mean
by that is like his build is very
identifiable but more than that his
tattoos on his face in his neck um so
there's a reason why people when you get
booked there's a reason why they take
photos of your tattoos right which uh
speaking of his tattoos um to me there's
a couple different things about his
tattoos there's a one underneath design
that looks like four dashes and a slash
of five that to me is the number 45. um
you know there's four dashes and then
the slash makes it a five that to me is
four and five right
that's to me and he also has a 47 which
some people have uh said that's for an
ak-47
but if you really think about the 45 and
the 47 numbers because the 47 is a lot
more recent tattoo than the uh the
dashes
under his eye that seemed to signify 45
and maybe i'm maybe i'm crazy maybe
that's not that's that's not it but um
it to me it looks like 45 and 47. but we
know who the uh significance of 45 would
be yep um we also know that maybe just
maybe there may be significance of the
number 47 right so it seems like that
this guy was willing to tattoo this [ __ ]
even on his face that he was a trump
supporter
yeah to me it seems like that maybe not
to others but yeah you know it it seems
very possible that you know 45 would
obviously represent uh you
know
[ __ ] trump and the possibility of him
coming in as 47
also makes sense you know um
uh we've got i've got a video here of
the motorcade
so here is uh
50 shades uh has um highland park
shooter
cheers as trump's motorcade passes by so
this is the video
i'm not sure exactly where this is at
gabe um and i don't know if you can tell
where this is at it's at an airport
because in the beginning of the video
that i pulled
you can watch trump's plane landing you
can hear people in the background saying
oh there he is there he is and it was
air force one because this is in 2020
when this video was posted when i pulled
it from the youtube channel before they
took it down because i've actually
pulled the full video or i had to screen
camp it actually because it wouldn't let
me download the son of a [ __ ] yeah um
so i had to i had to actually grab it
i robbed it um but the only reason why i
wanted to was because i thought it was
significant in that i wanted to make
sure to have a record of what that video
was in case these [ __ ] trumped-up
boneheads try to change it because i
know they're gonna try to change the
[ __ ] but here is the motorcade um and
watch at the very end this is uh the
piece of evidence that it's him but
watch at the very end
[Music]
it's an airfield i think is where
they're coming
and there it is so at the very end at
the very end and you can see the tattoos
he already has the 45 under the eye and
the 47 yeah there on his side um which i
think indicates that he is
um a trump supporter 45 and 47. that
would be me it doesn't
i don't know i mean like i'm trying to
think it look like an airfield so we
only have two really only two airports
in chicago and that's midway and that's
o'hare right but they would land him on
an airfield where they could actually
escort him right exactly so that because
he was because he was the president at
that time yeah so this also could be
some private airfield too that's smaller
for like you know people who are like
i'm a private plane owner and i want to
go fly around um they could be adjacent
to the airfield right because you
obviously haven't you know
it could be more secluded from the
actual bigger right right yeah yeah
because it's like all right we already
have a um
a sectioned off area that is you know
whatever zone is for airspace you know
to make sure that people aren't flying
within or or you know
again he was the trump was the president
of the united states at the time so they
were going to try to make sure that he
was very secure yeah and and landed in a
secure area and was able to be escorted
from the tarmac that he landed on very
securely um speaking of trying to secure
something here is um
here's the the little [ __ ] maga
ultra maga rooftop shooter being
arrested
this is the image from another car
across the intersection we saw a picture
from the fox news report there
overhead what looked like a news
helicopter possibly
or a traffic helicopter or a law
enforcement helicopter something was
above i can't see that in the video here
but he at this point in the video that
this person shot and i fast forwarded uh
to the point where he is out of the car
with his hands in the air it's hard to
see there but he is in out of the car
with his hands in the air but listen to
the dialogue because the the the officer
is giving him directions on the loud
speaker listen to what he asked him and
how he asked him to get on his knees
listen to this
you have to bear with me because there
is beeping in the background i think
with that i think this i don't know if
this person was doing that but these
that beeping reminds me of somebody who
is tracking
like you know what you would use when
you were younger which is like if you're
driving you're like oh i got to slow
down for cops in the area you know right
right it would give you a it would it
would detect radar so it would send you
a signal i think that's what it's
because the beeping kind of gets uh
faster and right maybe it's because the
cop car is getting closer they got their
radar on but again you see you see an
officer here
if you can see my mouse uh he was
actually across the intersection he's
come across he actually has a long rifle
here um and you see
um the ultra maga rooftop shooter here
with his hands in the air you can barely
see his hands here and the cop i i i'm
guessing somewhere in the cars behind
him are the ones that are dictating
orders through the loudspeaker listen to
what they ask him when they get on his
ease because they're asking him to take
his shirt off
um
and i'm guessing that's to identify him
maybe i'm not sure
they just want to make sure he doesn't
have any weapons on him probably um but
listen to when they ask him or how they
ask him to get on his knees
there's that beeping in them
all the way up all the way up they say
about his shirt
keep your shirt up keep your shirt up
[Music]
[Music]
do me a favor
get on your knees
yeah
why yeah
yeah
can you do me a favor here
while you're down there uh could could
you could you just you know slide the
gun over you know again what and the
other now that i'm thinking about the
reason why they might want to have his
shirt that put his shirt up is around
his his wrist right so if he keeps his
shirt up around his wrist he gets on the
ground it might be hard for him to you
know do anything um but there is
pictures and i'm not going to play the
rest of this video because that's
ridiculous do me a favor get on your
get on your face [ __ ] yeah i mean
they they talk to other people like that
hmm they even they even put 60 rounds
into other people when uh you know they
flee
because that that was some of the
argument yesterday too is oh well the
other guy fled they got 60 bullets like
no he fled too
this this guy
he was being
uh followed and he fled and they got him
at this intersect got him to stop at
this intersection
and i'm not sure why he stopped i guess
maybe he thought the
the jig was up but um
there is a picture here it is i'm gonna
show a picture of it here
uh here he is being arrested
um
on the ground
there uh at the scene
where he's being arrested
and you can see what he's you know
wearing black pants a red shirt which is
way off from what they were saying he
was wearing because at the time when
they were looking for him they were
saying he was either in a white shirt or
a
right a blue shirt i believe but i think
they were confused because he was he was
changing costumes to continue
i mean clearly
shows intent it wasn't just like in the
moment you know it was something that
was that was planned and that you know
had the whole strategy of how i was
going to go you know it was blending
back to the crowd it was very it was
like it's like oh hey you know i watched
a movie and you know i watched how this
assassin got away in the in the heat of
the moment you know and then it was like
i took that exact plan except i'm a
[ __ ] idiot and
you know
he is definitely a [ __ ] idiot um
again the news is that the suspected
suspected ultra mega rooftop shooter
highland park had been planning this for
weeks which i think months is probably a
more appropriate term but they're saying
weeks at this point um i don't know
exactly what evidence they're using to
determine that i want to turn just a
minute here to
a story that is um that that's been
being talked about this weekend and i
think it's getting buried and i think uh
i want to give it some air time here
there's a basketball player over in
russia
um
and what the hell it was trending and
it's not anymore are you kidding me
um i thought it would stay trending she
wrote a letter to president biden can
you give the audience a little bit of
background on greiner's story wildlife
until i find
that thread jesus christ they kidnaped
that threat isn't even
which is not there no it's well i mean
they're um
gets buried underneath the rest of this
stuff that's why i want to try to give
it some air time here right um so anyway
so yeah there's brittany griner uh
she what is it 130
i don't forget what that whether it's
like over 130 days that she's been
detained by russian
basically by russia uh and i think what
this weekend she wrote a letter because
she wrote a letter to biden you know uh
but this is you know the basically she's
she spent several you know um
she's you know wnba
she's playing in the russian premier
league earn additional income and then
uh she was under investigation after
customs officials claimed to have found
a sheesh oil in her luggage back in
february right right and and this is
right before they arrested her right
before
russia invaded ukraine right yeah yeah
it almost seems convenient it's yeah it
is a
yeah the timing but um you know she
wrote a letter and the letter says you
know as i sit here in a russian prison
alone with my thoughts and without the
protection of my wife family friends
olympic jersey or any accomplishments
i'm terrified i might be here forever
on the 4th of july our family normally
honors the service of those who fought
for freedom including my father who is a
vietnam war veteran it hurts thinking
about how i usually celebrate this day
because freedom means something
completely different to me this year
i realize you are dealing with so much
but please don't forget about me and
other american detainees
please do all you can to bring us home i
voted for the first time in 2020 and i
voted for you i believe in you i still
have so much good to do with my freedom
and that you can help restore i miss my
wife i miss my family i miss my
teammates
it kills me to know they are suffering
so much right now
i'm grateful for whatever you can do at
this moment to get me home
and i think the other thing too is i
i feel like obviously because you know
she has a wife she is not you know
russian russia is no fan of exactly
lgbtq not only that but it's like oh
she's not white she's not straight like
you know if there were things that they
were trying to
that they don't like
you know to go against her those are
certainly things that you know go in
their column
recount here has a tweet um it says
brittany granner's wife uh shereal i
think is how you say it says she has not
heard from president biden after the
letter from the wnba star was delivered
to the white house on the 4th of july i
will not be quiet anymore and the us
government is not moving they're not
doing anything um i actually would kind
of disagree with this fact initially um
because normally the us government if
they're going to do something like this
they're not going to they're not going
to try to say it out loud
um you know they're going to be quiet
about it but but again i understand the
frustration of the family
that they want her home and they should
be talking and yelling and screaming for
something to be done because they do
need to bring brittany home and they
need to bring her home now right it's
enough of this [ __ ] they need to get her
out of russia because and she's
obviously not safe there not just
because like you said she's an american
but she's also lgbtq and she's black
they definitely need to try everything
they can to get her and any other
detainees that they may have because
there's no telling what they might use
them for
with this war going on but let's listen
to her wife here uh talked to cbs this
morning initially
you know i was told you know
just we're gonna try and reserve you
know we're gonna try and handle this
behind scenes and you know let's not
raise her value and you know stay quiet
and you know i did that and and and
respectfully we're we're over 140 days
at this point that does not work and so
i will not be quiet anymore um i will
find that balance of you know harm
versus help in pushing our government to
do everything that's possible because
being quiet they are not moving they are
not doing anything and so
um my wife is struggling and we have to
help her
so i think she makes uh valid points
there but also um i think the government
has a valid point to keep this
to keep this at an armed links to
actually bring her home that's normally
how they're successful in these
operations um so but i think she should
keep speaking out i think the country
needs to know this that's why i wanted
to feature it as a story on the show
today because i think a lot of people
aren't paying attention to the story
that there's an american citizen over
there and
and here here's the thing is that um
when she does come home there's gonna be
some vile [ __ ] [ __ ] said some vile
[ __ ] [ __ ] said because she is black
she is a woman she is gay um she is
married to a woman there's going to be
some vile [ __ ] said about her when she
if
when she does return because i think she
will be uh she will return to the u.s um
there's a couple more trending topics
that i want to get to um bette midler
and i i don't want to shy away from this
i kind of thought about this this
morning i'm like i'm reading this and i
don't know
because i i really i
i'm a dude right i'm a dude i'm a man i
i really
i grew up around a lot of guys i did not
have a lot of
women in my life when i was younger
because all my cousins were boys um so i
don't i don't really but bette midler
tweeted something i guess this morning
or yesterday and she's getting a lot of
[ __ ] for it um and it seems like she's
it seems like to me
that she's talk she says the word they
um did you see this tweet
um
i don't know i mean i don't think so i
didn't see any tweet from her today
because uh elliot page is getting a lot
of um
a lot of transphobic stuff and then yeah
so eliot's elias pronouns are he they
i believe
or
yeah yeah well yeah
right whatever
um
whatever she's what whatever she's
identifying as but um she's getting a
lot of heat this morning
um for this elliot or bette miller well
well uh
both okay elliot page is getting a lot
of heat let me see in the trending
topics i believe elliot is still
and
trending here so yeah for anyone who
doesn't know the reason that elliot page
is getting a bunch of [ __ ] from people
is because if anyone watches umbrella
academy
uh i actually just finished the last
season this oh yeah yeah yeah he's he's
he's in he's in the uh the the seasons
before
before
he transitioned right right exactly and
so uh this this one this past season
is i thought they did i thought they did
a really good job of of telling the
story because elliot's character
uh transitions also
and becomes uh known as victor and so
they follow through and there's some
very nice moments and kind of
sentimental moments between
you know uh
his brothers and the family and all this
stuff in in the up in the season of
season three so basically a bunch of
people are being [ __ ]
transphobic and terrible humans against
elliot page
and
um
[Music]
elliot is more successful than them and
has more talent in them and they're
jealous and
that's really what it comes down to it
looks like jordan peterson is at the
heart of this story um i i guess i guess
they're saying that he was he's claiming
he was banned because he misgendered
elliot page which is a bunch of no give
me a [ __ ] break
we all know
we all know that the reason that jordan
peterson was removed from places like
twitter is because he
preaches hate
he attacks anyone who isn't a weights
white straight male
anyone who goes against
uh the
normal
uh gender
conformity that we have
and because elliott
transitioned
he's like
and tries to blame it on just a miss a
misgendering of then no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
no it's much more than that
this guy is the same person one on joe
rogan
and said oh you know i don't understand
why it's white and black and then joe
rogan goes yeah well black people i mean
they're not really black right yeah we
did a show on it i think right like 20
and then jordan peterson then had the
audacity to say
well i'm not even white i mean like i'm
like uh i'm i'm i'm tanner then it's
like homie you are paler than a ghost
okay
like if there was a spectrum
of white to black you would be whiter
and more transparent than casper the
[ __ ] ghost
i love how the racists are like well i'm
not as white as some people i get the
[ __ ] out of here uh here's here's what
bette mintler uh tweeted uh this uh
yesterday it was yesterday in the
morning um this is what's causing uproar
i read this and i'm trying to figure out
because i i want to be educated on this
there people are very upset um they're
saying that midler is being transphobic
here
she says women of the world we are being
stripped of our rights over our bodies
our lives and even our name
she says they don't call and i'm not
sure who the they is okay
i'm not sure who the they is but don't
call us women anymore they call us
birthing people
are menstruators and even people with
vaginas
um
that's that's what she's saying they
don't call us women they call us
birthing people menstruators and people
with vaginas don't let them erase you
every human on earth owes you i'm i'm
the thing i want to know is who is they
and them right yeah i mean you know i
i'm not saying that she is or isn't
being transphobic here well what i am
saying what i am saying is that for
people who
um
they get a little
again you you mentioned that elliot
page's pronouns are he and and
yeah right yeah no this is this is this
is referring to um
this because when i read this is they
don't call us women anymore they call us
birthing people or menstruators right oh
well okay
so because i could see there's one i'm
trying to figure out who i'm trying to
figure out who that they and them is
right right because when i see when i
see birthing people i would assume like
oh this is republican talking point
but then
unless there's unless there is something
that she's referring to in terms of
republicans like women aren't women
anymore
like just like you know well i i mean
there there is the
uh the documentary that matt walsh that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] with the daily
wire put out called uh what is a one you
know he really he can't figure out what
a woman is he's he's flabbergasted by
what a woman is
he doesn't understand that it's a gender
that you know a person identifies as he
can't figure that out
um which they made a whole movie on it
which is flabbergasting but they they
did and it's just to hate on trans
people
but i i i i'm again i want to be
educated here right yeah because i
actually when i read this a couple times
from from bette midler
i actually didn't
i i don't feel like she's attacking
trans people she maybe
are trying to
and i'm not sure right right like the
reason why i want to bring this up is
because i want people i think this is a
great discussion to have because
everyone's like pronouns don't matter
and if you talk about pronouns but the
pronouns in this tweet are actually what
matters the they and them
like
that's what who is she talking about
here right
right so that matters
yeah like i i look at it and i mean i
this is the first time i've seen this so
i'm coming here from uh just no context
right and
i mean like for people who you know who
don't know like things that are like i
first off i read and i go oh this is
definitely republicans
but then also i can understand where
someone might say that this is also kind
of you know this is turf language
which is like i'm a woman i'm a feminist
but i'm not going to include anyone else
who isn't
right because a lot of people are female
right like jk rowling is another example
of this right well and there was another
person trending this morning that went
on and i don't know who the [ __ ] that
person is gracie or something
i i put her in because there was a
trending topics macy gray i don't know
who macy gray is she was apparently on
uh
pierce morgan's saying some transphobic
[ __ ] and which was much more transphobic
than what bet here is tweeting or this
if this is transphobic it's not it
overtly
in in my opinion because i actually
don't know
and again i i if you're offended by it i
think you you absolutely should say
something yeah i have a hard time too
believing that bette midler is
transphobic maybe i'm wrong i i don't
know
um right i have a hard time believing
that but maybe that's true i i don't
know but i think this is worth the
discussion that's why i wanted to bring
it up um
because i think this points out of
why it's so important that people
actually be clear about who they are
talking about when they're talking about
they and them and and why it's so
important why someone would want to
identify as a certain pronoun like
that's
that's that's it like like why why is
this so difficult so and i i don't know
if this is a turf thing a terp is it
turf turkey yeah t-e-r-e-f
yeah i don't know if there's a turf
thing or or not but
um
this is the first this is the first time
seen of it i mean i have no idea if this
was i mean it you know
again even the most progressive liberal
people can be
not inclusive
which is right very unfortunate to know
and like that's what she's saying in
this like if that's what she's it's it's
whether it's whether it's like
it seems like she's attacking right it
seems like she's attacking trans people
if you read it a few times i had to read
it a few times and get and get that they
and them who that was right to hear it
that way um yeah but i but i would you
know it's one of those things where it's
like
you would imagine based on all the
feedback if this is not what you meant
to say or rather you're like i said what
i said and you interpret it as you
interpret it
like if a lot of people are saying hey
this is pretty transphobic and you're
not being inclusive
and she was
and she was like oh [ __ ] no no i didn't
mean it like that and she's like i just
want to clarify when i say they i meant
republicans or whatever
so the fact that she has continued to
post since yesterday at 8 28 a.m and
just done a lot of stuff that is you
know against calling out politicians for
the shooting and things like that
it makes me seem it makes it seem like
he did go through account i'm kind of
looking at her account i'm looking at
the tweet to see like is there anything
lately that's come up and everything
else is like oh you know
go to nyc and have a laugh go to see
billy crystal's mr saturday night or you
know go uh
um you know let's let's talk about the
hypocrisy you know
of the republican party of you know guns
and mental health and you know arming
people who should not have these guns i
mean she even she even posted this
um
it's a screenshot of another tweet and
says uh thank god pregnant 12 year olds
will no longer have to see a rainbow in
their classrooms while they're getting
shot at so right so if in fact people
are misinterpreting or m you know
or misreading the phrasing of whatever
she means like it would be one of those
things like oh
that's not what i meant i just let me
speak
because we've joked about that some of
these like scumbags like madison
gawthorne uh who who is uh who lost his
race because he's a he sucks sucks to
suck medicine but he he called them
earthen he called women earthen vessels
earthen vessels and they called them a
lot of other vile [ __ ] but it's not the
language she used in that tweet right
that's that's why i had to read it a
couple times because i'm like the things
she's saying that they're calling women
are not the thing that maga calls women
right right i i never
i mean maybe i'm wrong maybe there is
cases where they've called them
menstruators and
and what else did she call them
menstruators in this tweet
administrators birthing people
which the birthing people is really the
thing that kind of made me go yeah and
people with vaginas i'm like yeah that
really
yeah that seems you know like an attack
maybe
let's see
something about boris johnson
[Music]
uh um looks like two cabinet members
have quit um if ever anyone's following
um uh politics over his uh
cabinet yeah it looks like it um here's
the uh here's the quick headline from ap
here uh on the
trend um
two of
britain's most senior cabinet ministers
have quit to move
that could spell the end of boris
johnson's leadership so it looks like
boris johnson
may or may not uh their their trump may
or may not um
keep going even though he's there trump
did you see the interview where he's
like nah yeah biden's doing a good job
uh like like he said that well but
here's the thing
because everyone's like gas prices and
inflation like you realize that this
isn't an american thing right like the
only thing the only really the some of
the real problems we have here is taking
away people's rights and people shooting
people with guns like that's an american
thing
but the inflation and the gas prices are
not in a that's a worldwide problem that
we've got
it's not an american economy thing it's
a world economy and some of it is that
we're still
coming from
the effects of covid
the
almost two years that we had effects on
our economy from that but also
also the war in ukraine that russia has
decided that they want to you know
commit war crimes
and kill innocent people in ukraine and
so there's a lot going on with fuel and
inflation in some of these areas but
it's not
but it's not a worldwide problem and he
tried to convey that but boris johnson's
such a [ __ ] idiot yeah he's such a
[ __ ] idiot that he why why anyone
would air
anything that he says especially in
support of something that makes sense
because he is right about part of the
stuff what he's saying but then he says
really stupid [ __ ] you're like
oh my god the guy i mean the guy
is a fool right yeah but it's like
almost like trying to [ __ ] it's like
trying to stand in between a person and
a dart board when it's dark and they're
playing darts right like some of them
may not hit you right some of some of
the darts that he's throwing may not hit
you some of them are going to hit you
like yeah he's such a [ __ ] buffoon it
just
it's trumpism over there and it's it's
frustrating as hell that we continue to
do this nonsense um i mean fascism is
growing so well it is like 40 41
of france supports fascism basically
well you know that that um
that's how you already think about it i
don't know the exact figure but macron
did win uh yeah yeah he won however
it was more of a fight
than people expected you know it was
definitely was like oh the clear answer
is like hey don't do fascism right and
it was like uh
oh wow there's actually a percentage of
people that actually wouldn't be okay
with this got it all right oh breaking
news breaking news oh my god i can't
believe i'm gonna play this song
before we go here your boy joe rogan is
in the news here
oh man what's he taking some trt is he
gonna
go is it is he gonna interview trump
uh fox news is posting us joe rogan is
not having trump on the podcast
the quote is i'm not interested in
helping him ooh
breaking news breaking slap in the face
for the trumpers joe rogan joe rogan is
not interested in helping the person
that would probably if he took over as a
fascist murderous dictator yeah would
probably force joe rogan not to have
free speech right but what what i find
funny here is that joe rogan also you
know within the same breath of saying
i'm not gonna i'm not interested in
helping him he says desantis doing a
pretty good job he did a pretty good job
with covin let's ignore the fact that
they [ __ ] fudge the numbers and when
they when they had the audit that was
like three weeks ago that i that is what
was referenced in the interview that i
did with uh dr eric feiglding
is how
florida
they [ __ ] they massaged the numbers
they made it seem better than it was and
then they had an audit that went through
oh and turns out the whistleblower was
right about the whole way that desantis
was dealing with the [ __ ] data
oh you mean the one that they they they
kicked down their door and arrested so
he's actually running against uh matt
gates right right so i do want i want to
want to say one thing before we leave
because we are running out of time here
on the joe rogan thing in the desantis
thing
someone actually put in here i think
they
that they might have tweeted this
because i was expecting it and it sounds
like sounds like joe rogan has a new
daddy um
because let's let's face it this isn't
joe rogan coming to his senses here no
no this is right on the wall oh well i i
trump is gonna be indicted folks he's
gonna go to prison i i truly believe now
and we're going to have hearings next
week and you guys should definitely tune
in next week as the hearings commence
for the january 6 elect committee and
we're going to be producing those for
for midas touch um but
but he sees the writing on the wall that
trump is going to be a pariah and anyone
who claims to love trump is going to be
a pariah trumpism is going to switch
tyrannism
um and ronism is going to be ron
desantis and he's already broken
everybody on that train but the funniest
part about joe rogan supporting ron
desantis
is he is the most unfree speech
uh the most authoritarian to tell you
what the [ __ ] to do and when you can do
it he [ __ ] he doesn't want people to
have sex he doesn't want people doing
drugs
and joe rogan is the epitome of i'm free
speech and i'm a white dude and i can do
whatever i want whenever i want and here
he is supporting ron desantis who is not
for any of those things yeah yeah as
soon as he says
anything that would be against ron
desantis ronnie says like oh shut it
down shut it down right turn radio show
off you saw how he uh
was it it was grant right uh great
just just just look at just look at the
[ __ ] disney thing
disney went against one thing that ron
desantis said not even went against him
in the beginning they were not against
it or and the employees pushed disney to
be against it which they listened to
their employees thankfully disney did
that but ron desantis sent nazis up
there to protest actual nazis let's go
brandon nancy showed up wait wait wait
we actually do have i'm going to send
you the tweet right now okay uh thank
you thank you uh margie for it
um
before we go we'll just quickly leave on
this note so let's okay let's play the
brain you see
[Music]
at the the show now he's running the
show over there i'm running the show i'm
almost what is this
oh oh god oh my god breaking news
lindsey graham and rudy giuliani
subpoenaed and the georgia probe of
trunks election schemes this is exactly
why joe rogan says no [ __ ] way yeah
no way this guy's going to prison i want
nothing to do with him he's not going to
wrote me into this [ __ ] cheeto dust
kangaroo coo scheme i mean you got to
remember you know lindsey graham's the
one uh and you know i made i made fun of
it before but he's the one who showed up
or you know called uh raffensberger and
was like hey look so
we need to help trump out
how could we uh you know get rid of some
legal
mailing ballots right the ones that are
for body how do we toss those aside
right like that's the guy
and that's what he did right
that's lindsey graham trying to trying
to manipulate trying to rudy rudy
calling rudy giuliani oh yeah
and go come on we're all republicans
right we can cheat together right oh man
we're probably going to have more on
this tomorrow so don't miss the show
tomorrow go download today's episode at
on apple spotify google also follow the
youtube page subscribe here don't miss a
single episode and then follow us over
at tonymichaelspot on twitter i'm sure
we'll be tweeting about this event
follow me and gabe as well at the tony
michaels and that i am gabe sanchez
lindsey graham and rudy giuliani
subpoenaed [ __ ]
georgia probe of trump election scheme
great news great news to end on until
tomorrow folks surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking